he's one of the most powerful men in the
world
he was at that time
and
let me ask you the human question
as the old adage goes power corrupts and
absolute power corrupts absolutely
did you see
any corroding effects of power on the
man
forget the political leader i'm just the
human being that carries that power on
the shoulders
for so many years keep in mind that he's
been un
unlike most modern leaders he's been in
office
off and on because of there was a
medvedev was president and he was not
literally in charge
he was
he was he was uh he took another
appointment at that point and he but he
was still very much involved
but for 20 years more or less he's been
at the
administrator of the state the protector
of the state
and he's apparently done
a good enough job that the russian
people have kept him there because
contrary to what many people think i
really believe that if the russian
people didn't want him he would be out
i firmly believe that i don't think you
can let you can go against the will of
the people now it expresses itself in
many ways
at the ballot box and so forth but also
in other ways in russia there's a
strong occurrence of opinion so contrary
to what the
the position of him as a dictator he
wouldn't last if he was unpopular number
one number two russia is much more
divided than people know there's other
factors in russia he is there's there
are always tensions in in around the
kremlin
who has power who doesn't have power
that's been going on for
100 years but
the the factions in russia are
very much there so when people refer to
russia as putin they're they're mistaken
and they do this regularly in the new
york papers and all this they say putin
did this putin did that putin's doing it
but it's russia that's doing it
and that's what there's a distinction
there that i
it's changed in the old days
i would read about khrushchev but it was
never khrushchev personally it was about
the soviet union
uh there was respect for a country and
now when it started to get personal with
putin
it changed
and the our thinking changed in a
negative way we
we no longer respected it as a country
we were seen as a man and the man we had
trashed repeatedly
repeatedly as a poisoner as a murderer
none of which has ever been proven but
which has always been repeated and
repeated to the point at which it
becomes like an orwell
mantra it becomes like he is of course a
bad guy
you